JEN PERSON: This week, we're
talking about microtrends,
big events, and Blockchain.
Welcome to "This Week In
Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
If you've ever had questions
about the smartest way
to modernize your
infrastructure,
don't miss our Modernized
IT 2019 Conference.
Hear from experts and
get hands-on training.
Follow the link to check out
the schedule of sessions.
And if you can't tune
in live, no worries,
the sessions will be posted as
videos on the conference home
page afterwards.
Register now.
Until recently, running cutting
edge evolution strategies
for your ML algorithm
required a team of experts.
But thanks to the
manage capabilities
of Google Kubernetes Engine,
you can be the expert.
Read this tutorial to learn how
easy it is to implement an ES
algorithm on top of
Google Kubernetes Engine,
then try it out for yourself.
New applications for
Bigtable's powerful analytical
capabilities are
popping up every day.
The latest?
Financial microtrends.
Building time series
prediction pipelines
on Google Cloud Platform can
allow for real-time trends
down to the millisecond.
And it's easier than you think.
See?
Every step we took
to get our model up
and running, and start
predicting with your own data.
But why stop there?
Did you know that
you can use BigQuery
to build a hybrid
cloud Blockchain,
and that many GCP
customers already have?
Get a refresher on the history
of Blockchain and how it works.
Then learn about the benefits
of using BigQuery to automate
analysis of Blockchain
data, from SAS profit
sharing to detecting
software vulnerabilities.
What are you waiting for?
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.